It's been a while since we did a
Portainer video
and there is a terrible reason for that.
Portainer asked me to make videos showing people
how to operate Portainer in production.
I've done a few videos,
but ultimately I came to the same conclusion
over and over again.
Nothing is hard with Portainer.
It's all too damn easy.
Portainer has this very annoying habit of taking
complicated,
cumbersome,
complex tasks
and making them trivial.
Point, click, done.
So with that in mind, we're changing tact.
In this video, I'm going to take what
is traditionally a complicated and cumbersome and complex
task
and show how Portainer
makes it easy.
So
let's deploy in your EKS cluster on AWS
and get our application running with a GitOps
pipeline
all in under ten minutes.
Let's go.
Okay. So the first thing you're going to
need is obviously a Portainer running.
Here I am running the Portainer business edition
which is free for anything up to three
node.
I have also configured some production
credentials.
I've done this in advance because I don't
really want to show you any AWS credentials
on this video.
But you can see here, we have the
provider configured as AWS.
I've just called it production
and we've added an access key ID and
our secret access key.
To add these you just say add credentials,
fly to Amazon and fill in the form.
And keeping with Portainer,
it's pretty simple.
From here we can go to the Portainer
home screen.
Now you can see here we only have
a local environment,
that is the Docker engine that this Portainer
instance is running on.
We want to add a new environment.
So let's click on environment
and add.
From here, could say that we wish to
provision
a Kubernetes
cluster.
We select our cloud provider
and give our cluster
a name.
Here I will call it Rawkode test.
You can then set the region you wish
to deploy it to.
As I'm in Scotland, I'll choose London down
in England.
Next you can change your AMI type,
the instance size,
your disks,
the number of nodes
and even the Kubernetes version.
None
of this is particularly important for today's video.
So we're just gonna go straight ahead and
click revision.
Now let's go back to our environment page
where we'll see
that our agent is now
provisioning an AWS EKS cluster.
Now while Portainer does amazing things at taking
complicated complex tasks and making them trivial or
easy,
it cannot speed up the provision of an
EKS cluster.
So we'll be back with some movie magic
in just a moment.
Alright.
The dance has been danced, and we have
the Rawkode test AWS
EKS Kubernetes cluster running.
Let's
get our application deployed.
To do this we can just jump back
home
and set the Rawkode test environment
as our current environment.
This opens up all of Portainer's Kubernetes tools
including browsing the namespaces and resources within a
cluster.
Here we can see the default namespace.
Now this is a new cluster with nothing
installed so we're not going to see too
much.
So let's click on applications
and create our manifest.
From here we can add a GitHub
URL or any Git repository URL.
Here I'm going to deploy the Google Cloud
Platform microservice
demo.
Next, we can specify the path to the
gamma we wish to apply.
Which in this case is release
Kubernetes
manifest and you can see Portainer is now
auto completing the path from the repository.
And that's it.
We go back to the top,
call this
microservice
demo,
and hit deploy.
Portainer is now cloning this repository
and applying our manifest from the release directory
to the cluster.
And as you can see it's discovered the
ad service, cart service and so forth, all
of the microservice examples from this repository.
Now currently it says replicated zero of one
but if we give that a few minutes
for the cluster to pull the images and
get these replica sets and pods running,
we will start to see green and one
zero one across the board.
Like so.
So now that we have our application deployed,
we probably want to check that it worked.
Now we can see all the applications here
including our front end.
From here we can see that it's in
the default namespace,
it has an internal service with a cluster
IP and an external load balancer type service
with external access.
We can see the environment variables passed in
to this pod.
We can also see the events to see
if the pods have been restarted or if
anything is wrong
fetch the log.
Or in the event that something goes wrong,
jump to application
and ask for the logs.
But
maybe
your developers don't always want to access the
UI.
Perhaps
you want to use the CLI
and that's okay too.
WebProtainer
you have the choice.
Now typically what you could do is
generate a KubeConfig and give it to someone
in your team
but then you have to worry about them
sharing that KubeConfig
or
getting the AWS IAM authenticator or the recent
version of the AWS CLI in order to
be able to authenticate and they also need
to have AWS access blah blah blah blah
blah. Giving people access to your cluster
isn't really that easy to do well,
but we have Portainer.
It has user management. We could invite our
entire team and even configure SSO.
Check out the video in the course for
that.
So if you want to hook in
to that I'm policy in our back
then the developers or anyone you wish can
just use the cube control shell button.
I click this
and right in my browser,
I can run
kubectl
commands.
I can now see all of my services
including
the host name to access our load balancer
service
and there we go
this is the Google microservice
demo
running on EKS
provisioned by Portainer.
Your life made easier.
So there you have it.
While I couldn't make the video Portainer wanted
me to make because they just make things
too simple,
I hopefully showed you how Portainer
can simplify
other things too.
We all need Kubernetes clusters.
Hopefully, you're using a managed provider.
Portainer gives you a simple interface to spin
up those clusters on demand.
We can then set up GitOps pipelines either
manually like I did or using Edge stacks.
Check out the video in this course to
see how you can automate the rollout of
your application to one or many clusters using
Portainer.
The convenience of the UI is there if
you want it and the CLI is just
a click away too.
Portainer is a fantastic tool.
I hope you found this video useful. Until
next time. Have a great day.